good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight Kanye West now known as
yay is one of the best-selling musical
artists in the world he's also in recent
years becoming celebrated and very
highly paid fashion designer and of
course for a decade he was well known to
TV audiences as an in-law of the
Kardashian family but it's West's latest
Incarnation is a kind of Christian
evangelist that brought us to his office
in Los Angeles today for the interview
you're about to see
days ago during Fashion Week in Paris
West accompanied by his friend Candace
Owens unveiled a t-shirt that read
simply White lives matter
the response from the fashion industry
and international media was
instantaneous and uniform shock horror
rage there is no excuse for this
thundered the New York Times West is
legitimizing extremism shrieked Rolling
Stone
etc etc
what was strikingly missing from the
coverage whoever was any explanation for
why West did this what was the T-shirt
about
no one seemed to think to ask him much
less to listen to what he had to say
instead the enemies of his ideas
dismissed West as they have for years as
mentally ill too crazy to take seriously
look away ignore him he's a mental
patient there's nothing to see here
but is West crazy
you can judge for yourself as you watch
what we're about to show you he has his
own ideas we can say that creative
people tend to that's why they're
artists not actuaries his free-form
social media posts give the impression
of a man channeling his rawest emotions
right onto Instagram the effect can be
jarring and it's often used as
ammunition against him in the battle for
influence over the minds of America's
young people and that battle is intense
but crazy
that was not our conclusion in fact
we've rarely heard a man speak so
honestly and so movingly about what he
believes but again you can judge for
yourself here it is subscribe to the Fox
News YouTube channel to catch our
nightly opens stories that are changing
the world and changing your life from
Tucker Carlson tonight